[Applaudissements]
ouais et il a relevé les compteurs mais
j'ai fait les embryons ils peuvent
atteindre magique pour mon ami sans
frais dans le prix au kg pour savoir
quoi penser ça pour mettre toutes ses
sorties
vous savez que ce soir les bleus
affrontent la croatie
bien sûr lille b alors user moi qui
adore le foot me suis pas ça parce que
la ligue des nations ses conseillers qui
joue on nous paie a en fait ça mène ou
cet hiver
pourquoi laisser la digue délation quoi
ça sert à quoi bah c'est une compétition
qui sert à rien bah oui ouais mais c'est
que ces médias c'est vrai ça sert à rien
ouais merci
n'hésitez pas de mandat
à face aux joueurs de l'équipe de france
parce que je sais qu'il nous regarde pas
touche aux cheveux de killian non ok
parce qu'après le match contre le
portugal
regardez ce qui s'est passé monkey diane
qui se fait beau gosse pour les
journalistes giroud qui lie bravo à tout
le monde
[Applaudissements]
ce sacré j'adore cyanide roland
n'importe quelle tenue spéciale d'envoyé
spécial des voisins qui n'aiment pas
leurs voisins par les deux voisins à
d'autres voisins break tout ça vivement
la fête des voisins aura sur les
insultes ce qui revient très souvent ce
sont les histoires de voisins bruyants
madame quels mots les utiliser si ça
m'habite c'est pour ça
[Applaudissements]
elle relate les faits voilà comme ça
non non non ça ne mord s'annonça non non
il est allé danser mon choix sur steam
est exactement dans ces monceaux on a eu
droit spécial sosies alors là un grand
bravo aux équipes de casting qui ont
fait un travail
bluffant on a dit que je ressemblais à
souk arabe a demandé à tony parker s'est
pas flagrant on a dit que je ressemblais
à beinheim
[Applaudissements]
j'ai bien reçu cette jeune fille je me
rappelle j'ai fait une émission où j'ai
pris des anonymes dans le public exergue
un jour et où elle avait pris votre plat
exact est très sympa ta est très sympa
ouais pas dehors sans combinaison c'est
la même personne y est très jolie
d'ailleurs
oui voilà bah oui attendez vous aimez le
sport
oui mais la poésie c'est la minute sport
et poésie avec le coach de l'équipe de
rugby de bordeaux christophe urios être
écrit vous allez voir est un peu les
boules du matin sans déconner ça joue
les bleus je pense que je vais je crois
plus boulot et après après devedjian
groupe le plus bout leurs plus fervents
ciel joue un peu comme jean rozat parce
que parfois la nasse 28 les mouches à
magnifique n'a pas tort tu as beau
témoignage avec 90 minutes en quête
exactement 90 minutes enquête enquête
exclusive enquêtes prioritaires arc en
aidant la police
c'est beaucoup une enquête mais pas que
alors on se pose une question mais que
fait la police
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la police et du suspense et des
arrestations musclées
le danger peut venir de partout
et mieux vaut avoir le coeur bien
accroché la police sait faire face à des
intelligences venu d'ailleurs de
certains disent la police et des courses
poursuites de fully
[ __ ] c'est bains de mer et la police
est aussi identifier les plus dangereux
suspect en cavale
[Musique]
il est des blonds aujourd'hui il est
orange est centrale pour luigi vous avez
dit boulanger c'est bon je crois qu'on
mal à personne
[Musique]
je pense à moi et skoda d'autres chaînes
et pour finir ça fait un petit moment
qu'on n'avait pas signé d'étape en
philosophe académiciens prof de français
c'est votre moment c'est le knicks à g
et on n'a pas danser collé-serré non
plus donc un moment donné pour arrêter
de tout extra police et on en vendra
pour 10
désolé d'avoir mis à mal à l'aise la
pelouse en nappe ses pairs original
appelez-moi l'improvisé mais maintenant
tu sais ma toile va être vendue pour une
oeuvre charitable de karité vite et tu
me fais penser à marineland rollin là
tout de suite la récitation annoncé le
juge pas que j'y vais pour ça j'ai pas
trop de cotisations culinaires et en
attendant autre tenue au alors là je
grille de mille et une façons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]